in dieser woche haben sich die
finanzminister der g20 staaten endlich
auf eine mindeststeuer für konzerne wie
amazon geeinigt das sind erfolg auch für
olaf scholz persönlich bei einem sagen
wir mal verwandten thema haben wir
allerdings noch sehr viel luft nach oben
die rede ist von geldwäsche
nächsten monat nächsten monat kommt die
internationale finanz task force mtf bei
uns zur kontrolle vorbei die haben
deutschland schon beim letzten besuch
eine 5 - verpasst und zwar mit mit brief
an die eltern freunde ja nein es nicht
nicht übertrieben gesagt um ein haar
wären wir damals sogar auf deren
schwarzer liste gelandet neben pakistan
iran und nordkorea ist kein witz ja
wissen viele nicht deutschland ist und
bleibt halt ein geldwäsche paradies wenn
wir da überhaupt mal was ermitteln dann
eher aus versehen eher zufällig kamen
die ermittler der bande auf die spur im
mai 2020 fand die polizei in einem
unfallwagen meinen nettetal einen
turnbeutel mit 300.000 euro die in die
türkei gebracht werden sollten so das
ist mal ein turnbeutel vergessen
wer sich wirklich geärgert hat ja ganz
blöde sache mama hatte seinen namen in
den turnbeutel genäht und
so haben sie ihn gekriegt
so auch die italienische mafia fühlt
sich bei uns weiter pudelwohl ja ja und
das ist dass es kein wunder wenn man in
italien mit einer großen badezimmer auf
liegt muss man dann nachweisen dass das
geld legal verdient wurde ihr bei uns
reicht es immer noch zu sagen habe ich
beim kniffel geworden geldwäscher wollen
eigentlich wissen wenn sie hier eine
immobilie erwerben dass sie in den
vielen jahren noch gehört und dass der
staat nicht irgendwie so marode ist dass
die sorge haben müssen dass sie auch ihr
kriminelles vermögen wieder los sind
also sie können hier sozusagen
rechtssicher geld waschen und anlehnen
ja in deutschland kann man recht sicher
kriminell sein dass so ein
standortvorteil ganz klar
kommen es ist ja irgendwo auch ein
kompliment wenn einem sogar mexikanische
drogenkartelle vertrauen
wenn ich mafioso wäre würde ich auch
mein geld in deutschland anlegen also
sagen 'hey ich das zitat das sagt der
oberstaatsanwalt von palermo auf
sizilien läuft regelmäßig diese werbung
man findet man ja und dann ihr brach der
muckibude
rechnet man die trips sporty soll
indes
christian constantin l brut easy modus
oder licht gerade komplett einen langen
vorlauf grube lehnte bruder die
politische diskussion
die
man so noch besser konnte guido morini
channel
nichts tun
keiner
keiner muss da vor uns angst haben weil
wir so gastfreundlich sind eben nicht
nach der herkunft fragen also bei
menschen die rein wollen schon klar aber
eben nicht beim geld die eu möchte schon
seit jahren im zahlungsverkehr in europa
eine einheitliche bargeld obergrenze wir
wollen die einführen deutschland ist
immer noch strikt dagegen allerdings mit
einer absolut wasserdichten begründung
das bargeld ist in deutschland sehr
beliebt und wir wollen jetzt nicht das
kind mit dem bade ausschütten da eben
nein es ist halt einfach zu beliebt
ganze mietshäuser mit einer aldi tüte
voller scheine zu bezahlen will die
ampel vielleicht ändern ich meine man
muss ja nicht so weit gehen wie schweden
das ab 2023 komplett bargeldlos wird
genaueres gibt schöne bargeld tradition
bei uns wie diese omas die an der
supermarktkasse quälend langsam
alte rechtshänder aus ihrer handtasche
rauskommen das soll bleiben aber gegen
eine obergrenze im zahlungsverkehr
spricht gar nichts was ist das bei uns
für ein komischer fetisch mit dem
bargeld im frankfurter bankenviertel
haben jetzt plötzlich wieder die alten
peepshows aufgemacht nur dass ich da
keine nackten frauen mehr regeln sondern
nackte unmarkierte scheine
bleibt der juni die alte post
entschuldigung ja aber vorsicht in
solchen etablissements kommt es
natürlich auch schnell mal zu einer
scheinschwangerschaft
nochmal entschuldigung es ist es ist
tatsächlich sehr seltsam wie wenig sich
die deutsche öffentlichkeit über
geldwäsche aufregen genau wie über
steuerhinterziehung dabei clowns
steuerhinterzieher uns allen jedes jahr
über 50 milliarden euro und es scheinbar
kaum ein dass wir immer noch viel zu
wenig steuerfahnder haben in diesem land
ja die die steuerfahndung braucht
mindestens 25 prozent mehr personal zu
media so gut wie nie ein großes thema
aber als neulich der finanzminister von
baden württemberg ein anonymes melde
portal für steuerbetrug vorgestellt hat
riesen aufschreiben wir sollten uns alle
gegenseitig verpetzen das ist doch stasi
2.0
als ob man die deutschen motivieren
müsste ihren nachbarn anzuzeigen hören
dass man das machen wir wenn die
biotonne 1 cm zu weit links stehen es
ist wirklich ein heuchlerisches
lächerliches theater solche melde
portale gibt es in vielen bundesländern
und wie funktionieren astrein
ein paar schicke gehabt und grafik teilt
hier stimmt was nicht
[Musik]
ich froh dass ich nur jungs haben die
kriegen je nix mit so was die geldwäsche
angehen bräuchten wir endlich eine
richtige finanzpolizei stattdessen haben
wir die sogenannte fi die financial
intelligence unit ich zitiere mal einen
lange unter verschluss gehaltenen
bericht des bundesrechnungshofes es
besteht vor allem die gefahr dass die
ewu sachverhalte in bezug zur geldwäsche
und terrorismusfinanzierung nicht
erkennt und ihrem gesetzlichen auftrag
nicht gerecht wird
klingt nicht gut für dich seit 2017 ist
der laden beim zoll angesiedelt und hat
zuletzt immer mehr mitarbeiter bekommen
reicht aber lange nicht sagt unter
anderem die gewerkschaft der polizei wir
schalten live nach köln dellbrück zu
gisa flaake sie leitet bei der eu die
abteilung für unorganisierte
verbrechensbekämpfung frau flacke woran
hakt dennoch ja woran gute frage da
müsste ich jetzt wirklich raten klar
eine möglichkeit wäre natürlich dass wir
hier jeden tag leisten werden mit
verdachtsmeldung von banden jubilieren
autohändlern allein 2020 sind
144.000 davon hier ein geflattert und da
soll wir in kürzester zeit erkennt was
verdächtig ist wie soll das gehen
ich habe gelesen er arbeitet mit einer
software die verdächtiges rausfiltern
daher genauso oft wäre ich kann mir mal
wie unsere filter software funktioniert
sagt überweisung rausgefiltert so was
steht da zehn millionen empfänger prinz
von nigeria verwendungszweck illegaler
waffen haben
ja also das könnte jetzt alles mögliche
bedeuten
olaf scholz erzählt in interviews gern
wir würden bald künstliche intelligenz
einsetzen
ja genau hier aus dem geheimen
rechnungshofbericht zum zeitpunkt des
jeweiligen meldung eingangs war nur ein
empfang von verdachtsmeldungen per fax
bei der fa juni
eine liebe die niemals endet warum habe
ich habe mal versucht das suchen auf
meinen faxgerät aber da kommt nichts
raus hier sitzen kein witz zum teil
arbeitslose und studenten eine meldung
von dich vom fax in den computer
übertragen ich verstehe was würde der eu
denn konkret helfen
wenn wir zum beispiel eines tages mal
zugriff hätten auf die daten von bka und
bundespolizei behörden wie in
zivilisierten ländern aber jetzt fange
ich wirklich an zu träumen bis dahin
heißen wir übrigens auch nicht nur
sondern
warum
ich das geräusch das entsteht wenn den
bogen statt wie immer wieder kriminelle
geld durch die lappen geht
was für geld schweißte sie denn da
dieser flog ihn an
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und 70 - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal der stelle